- Every now and then I'll take
a hit of whatever you've got.
I don't care if it's a
upper or downer or whatever.
I just like to, you know, smoke
a joint every now and then.
(upbeat music)
Well, hey there.
Look, it's Willie.
- [Voiceover] In Austin,
Texas, there's a massive statue
immortalizing the city's
most-celebrated resident.
Upon the sculpture's
installation, Willie said,
"I'll be stoned 1,000 years."
Is it funny to you how famous
you've become for the pot?
- Yeah, it's hilarious.
(laughing)
It is.
Well, you know, I spent
enough time in jail,
and I feel like I've bought enough of it,
so I feel like I could be
able to sell some back.
- [Voiceover] So he is.
Willie's planning to launch
his own brand of marijuana
called Willie's Reserve.
- Well, I don't know how cool it is,
but I think it's the right thing to do,
you know, if you believe in it.
In the past few years,
it's been proven that we were right,
that it is a medicine,
that it is helpful to millions of people.
I think most people are educated now,
at least more than they were,
that it's not a killer.
I don't know of anybody who's
ever died from smoking pot.
Friend of mine died when
a bale of it fell on him.
(squelching)
But, other than that...
- [Voiceover] So, other than that,
to him, it's worth fighting for.
And take his word for it, even at 83,
the man's lungs are still able to play
upwards of 100 shows every year.
- I'm sort of like the canary in the mine.
I've been here a while and
whatever it's done for me,
positive or negative, here it is, you know.
I think I'm doin' all right.
I think the water's fine,
you know, come on in.
(gentle music)
(chiming)